[Music]
you pause for the Queen's death how did
that affect the um production when she
passed away well everyone was extremely
sad and I think everyone
well I know I was
very I'm sort of inconsolable that
evening I was off for 10 days and I was
very grateful for that time off
to sort of just settle back down and
then we filmed the day after the funeral
and I felt it was difficult for the
other people looking at me they were all
looking at this um an actor playing the
person who had been buried yesterday and
so it was odd and I think there was a
great sense of sadness following the
Queen's death the crown was criticized
for its portrayal of the royal family
named Judy Dench called it cruelly
unjust and completely inaccurate how did
it come to this what was your reaction
to the calls for disclaimers you know
it's a bit unnecessary and if people
don't know it's a fiction by now then
there's you know it's it's sad I mean
you know you can think of all sorts of
examples of other things that you might
have to put a disclaimer in front of at
this interview for instance I won't go
quietly I'll battle till the end
Elizabeth Debicki portrays Princess
Diana Dominic West is Prince Charles and
we've got a behind the scenes look at
season 5 out November 9th on Netflix
which focuses on their crumbling
marriage in Charles's affair with
Camilla the great tensions that you see
in this season is between this 1950s
Outlook and the modern day and how they
clash and how Diana really represents
the modern day and and Charles is sort
of caught between the two well the three
of us in this marriage it's a bit
crowded as a result of the marriage
breaking down and how she becomes more
and more removed from the rest of the
royal family that of course sort of
encourages her to grow other pieces of
her life and attempt to sort of recoup
control of the ones that feel like
they're spiraling
foreign